so I saw Godzilla for a second time
tonight I took my mom my mom's awesome
she loves Godzilla she wants to go watch
x-men in Captain America and stuff like
that I have a great mom I have a great
dad - he loves Star Wars he quotes Star
Wars lines all the time I'm getting off
on a tangent
my parents are awesome that's all I'm
saying so I'm here to talk to you guys
in full spoiler glory about the new
Godzilla film so if you have not seen
the film check out my spoiler free
review which is on my channel right now
I have warned you let's proceed
I really enjoyed Godzilla yes there is a
lack of Godzilla for certain parts of it
you're a little bit left like I wanted a
little more Godzilla and I can agree
with that although there is about 15 to
16 minutes a Godzilla in this movie
there's about the same amount of time
for Jaws in the same amount of time for
the dinosaurs in Jurassic Park and the
same amount of time for Hannibal in the
Silence of the Lambs but those were
portioned out a little bit better and so
they kind of felt normal but in this
movie there are a few moments like
mailing the second act really like I
would love to see a little more Godzilla
please and in my original review I
mentioned there's an emotional thing
that kind of happens near the beginning
that I thought detracted from the depth
of the film dramatically and what that
was I couldn't say it in my review as
Bryan Cranston dies because I thought
that he added so much to that first act
and he was such a cool character much
more of an interesting character that I
thought than Aaron taylor-johnson
character and so I kind of wanted him to
stay alive and actually maybe have the
movie be a father-son bonding experience
I think that might actually have made
for a better movie I think if they would
have just done that with Bryan Cranston
had that be the story of the film a
father-son bonding experience and then
shown a little more of the Hawaii
Honolulu fight that we don't get to see
then I would have given this film an A+
I stand by my a minus grade though and I
saw this film a second time I actually
enjoyed it a little bit more the second
time which is very rare for me I think
the reason I did enjoy it a little bit
more because I went into it knowing
things like Bryan Cranston dies and
there wasn't going to be as much
Godzilla in a certain part of this movie
that you may want since I knew those
things I was able to just sit back and
enjoy the ride and really this is a
magnificently directed movie there's
definitely a lot of Spielberg E and
flare in there some of the Jurassic Park
elements that I said we're kind of
tributing it we're like how it opens
with
helicopter and the big forest mountain
shots and everything the part where the
bus driver wipes the hot air off the
window the part where the Muto's hand
comes over and starts to tear at the
cables reminded me of the t-rex hand
coming over and ripping the cables down
Jurassic Park I don't think it's as good
of a film as Jurassic Park I do think
there were definitely some visual
tributes in there all-in-all I had so
much fun with Godzilla because you
really actually were put in the role of
the humans and you actually felt like
okay this is what a human would
experience during this that mesmerizing
shot through his goggles as they fell
from the plane we saw Godzilla and
everything coming through the clouds
that blew my mind see I knew there was
some other creature in the movie but I
knew nothing about it I stayed away from
all clips I watched the first two
trailers and that was it I had no idea
what the thing looked like so I was able
to actually experience all this for the
first time in the theater which is so
cool because they really did hide a lot
from the trailers I went back and
watched the trailer again and you don't
see a single shot from the third act so
the fire-breathing moments were amazing
can you imagine if Sony got their hands
on this trailer the trailer would like
open with Bryan Cranston's head the
zipper going over him he's always dead
that sucks the third act of this movie
you know just sitting in the theater
watching these three creatures go at it
was incredible the sound effects were so
amazing and I got to say the second time
I appreciated Alexander des PLAs score
the first time for the second time I was
really able to focus on it it's so
intense and it really adds a lot to the
action in this film I also love the
whole thing about Godzilla being the
balancing force that nature offers to
balance out this crazy thing between
these two Muto creatures
that's so cool to me because it just
made him seem like this epic thing that
just Rises when it's needed but in my
original review I alluded to two cheer
worthy moments and by far they're the
fire-breathing elements the way he
defeats the creature by breathing fire
down its throat I just like sigh was is
like that is the greatest thing ever
that just looks so cool but the shot in
the film where my eyes actually kind of
teared up a little bit in nerdly dork
awesomeness was when up and up
Godzilla's legs for the first time
showed his face and he looked so vicious
and fierce and they just did that roar
it was so incredible I just wish they'd
shown more
fight you know I get they don't have to
show the whole things maybe Godzilla
bites him and kind of flings them and he
flies off or something you know just a
little bit more right there would have
been amazing the way the film opened
with Bryan Cranston losing his wife
right in front of him was so intense and
I love the way it's set up his character
and that's why I wanted his character to
be around for longer because he was the
character that you really from beginning
are with and it's like okay yes I'm with
you man you're the bomb and you're a
really freaking good actor I just wanted
more of his character because it sets
you up for that you know it kind of
makes you want to experience the film
through him yes I wish there was a
little bit more Godzilla in the film
overall I had such an enjoyment from how
well directed it was how intense the
action was and the incredible third act
I love how they made Godzilla a good guy
I just love that whole nature balancing
out nature type of thing that they made
him and how he just trudges out of San
Francisco and he's all tired he's I'm
just gonna go swim for a while yes there
was as much Godzilla in it as you may
expect some of the human drama isn't as
good as it could have been and that's
why I didn't give it a perfect grade I
think if they had boosted those two
things then I would have given it an A+
but it had some problems but I really
enjoyed this film and I'm really hoping
they do a sequel Godzilla vs.
Mechagodzilla godzilla vs. king kong um
thank you so much for watching guys and
as always if you liked this you can
click right here and get stuck my next
Oh